un cadre prestigieux des cavaliers de
haut niveau 200 chevaux et un public de
connaisseurs bienvenue au jumping
international cinq étoiles de versailles
pour la première fois la compétition
était organisée du 5 au 7 mai dans les
grandes écuries du château
hilali l'organisation d'une grande
compétition internationale à au
patrimoine en étant au sein des écuries
du château de versailles
c'est une réussite exceptionnelle de
pouvoir avoir organisé ce concours et
ensuite la france inscrit dans sa
tournée de concours internationaux parmi
les plus grandes nations habitante et le
belle image au monde entend au casting
de cette première édition des champions
olympiques tricolores comme kevin staut
originaire du chéné star du cinéma
français guillaume canet mais également
l'une des légendes de ce sport le
brésilien de 44 ans rodrigo pessoa
médaillé d'or aux jo de 2004 et
vainqueur de 50 grands prix
internationaux tout au long de sa
carrière en équipe de réalisation sont
des amis de puits a depuis longtemps
relaxé un de mes partenaires aussi
depuis 19 ans donc ils m'ont demandé
d'être ambassadeur du du concours de
l'événement j'ai bien évidemment accepté
qu'il fait je devais être ici de très
bons très bons cavaliers c'est la
compétition très relevée sur les
prochains jours l'organisation de ce
jumping permet également de promouvoir
la candidature de paris aux jeux
olympiques de 2024
si le dossier retenu les épreuves
équestres pourrait s'y dérouler c'est
pas une répétition parce que ça
ressemble en rien de ce que ce rallye
seront des jeux olympiques mais en tout
cas c'est d'amener tous les acteurs qui
ont une action à tous les lieux
différents niveaux de rencontrer déjà le
site les actes auront l'occasion de
découvrir encore un peu plus le site sur
les prochaines éditions
le partenariat entre le château de
versailles et les organisateurs du
jumping international est signé jusqu'en